hey in fact is my third dear dear PC
series and this time I'm going to answer
your question another question I get
pretty frequently actually so this one
this writer is said I know HTML CSS
JavaScript jQuery blah blah blah
I followed lots of tutorials to make
simple sites and but now I'm stuck what
do I do next
what can I use to start building
something like I want to actually build
something I've kind of like this
question a lot and I've also been in his
position before as well so you might you
know you might be in the same position
where you've kind of gone through a
bunch of tutorials you learned a bunch
of stuff you maybe spent a bunch of time
learning syntax and things like
conditionals and data types and classes
and so forth so you kind of collected a
bunch of knowledge here and there we are
like what what's kind of next right you
actually want to build something but it
feels like you have a bunch of disparate
knowledge and you don't know how to put
everything everything together I think
the answer to this will be a little bit
different for everyone because there's
no way I can sit here and tell you the
exact steps of what to do next but I'll
kind of give you a framework for how to
think about your next step once you've
kind of reach this position where you're
no longer just learning the basics but
you want to get to the next step so
first thing I would say let's take a
step back and remember why you want
start learning end up learning to
program in the first place right so I
think I obviously agree that everyone
should learn to program but I think it's
a good starting point to understand what
you personally want to get out of it
are you trying to be the best designer
are you trying to be a web developer are
you trying to be a mobile developer so
you can build a mobile app or are you
trying to just use programming for your
own personal hacks that you want to
script up or are you trying to maybe
build your grandma's website for her
bakery whatever it is
think about think back to the time that
you started programming and think back
to the time of why you got so motivated
to learn to program and personally I
want to learn to code because I want to
build this learning app where I can use
writing techniques to help you
or anything that you've ever read and I
was really passionate about being
bringing this idea to life and I want to
learn the skills to bring this idea to
life so for me it made sense to learn
web development and so depending on what
you're trying to accomplish
you can figure out what you need to
learn right and regardless of whether it
is honestly it doesn't matter just
remember that goal and keep it in the
back of them ask back of your mind
because that's what's going to make
motivate your day to day so that's the
big picture and then before going to
that huge lofty goal that got you
started
you think smaller right you have to get
started somewhere so personally what I
did was I choose a problem that I want
to solve at work so at the time I was
working in andreessen horowitz and I
want to build a web application that
would help entrepreneurs understand
software as-a-service metrics so one of
my focus areas when I was there was I'd
focus on SAS businesses and a lot of
entrepreneurs sometimes didn't really
understand how to analyze the businesses
and how to how to understand the metrics
and I kind of want to create this
website that would have like a flow
diagram those clickable and you can get
the definitions you can get the
relationships between the different
metrics and so forth so is this kind of
pretty simple web web app one single
page web app and for you it doesn't
really matter what you pick as your
first project
honestly just pick something that you
care about enough that when stuff goes
wrong because stuff will go wrong you're
still motivated and inspired to keep
going and frankly it's not like this is
the last application you're ever going
to build right you're just going to
build a ton more this is just the first
one so you start somewhere pick
something that you care about and maybe
over time you can even rebuild that
better and better two three four times
as you become a better programmer so so
I had this idea of this application so
what I did was I mapped out the ID I
figured out who the target users are for
the features I want this app to have
what is the functionality I want to have
the look and feel of it for me design
and the look and feel things really
motivate me I get really motivated by
seeing something beautiful so that's
something that I really want to
accomplish with this application and
then
drawing some rough sketches and then I
try to put together just like the HTML
skeleton for it sells it here's the
header here's the body user subheaders
here's the different boxes where these
metrics will go and I had like a side
navigation so I started floating the
basic HTML together then I added a bunch
of CSS for the visual stuff and making
it look pretty
and then lastly able to go on to add
JavaScript so the core thing is I
started very simple I knew I just wanted
a single page I didn't want to have to
deal with routers and all that I had no
servers back-end it was all just fun and
JavaScript HTML and CSS and once I got
this version out then I started to kind
of layer on other stuff so I want to
learn how service work and I wanted to I
was holding a lot of their logic in the
data in the front-end and I want to
really store that and have a server
handle a lot of this logic and data and
so what I did was I learned note I went
through a few tutorials and went through
the documentation and then I figured out
just like with a lot of fiddling and
learned how to add a node server and it
got that node server working and I
remember the moment that I got working I
was like oh my god this is awesome and
then next up was I learn how to build an
API right so I had a simple router and I
built an API and then I figured out how
to get the front-end to talk to the API
and that was like a big moment for me
and then I was like okay I'm storing a
lot of my definitions and data on in
like a local file I want to move this to
a database so then I went through a
bunch of tutorials to learn my sequel I
learned my sequel and then I learned how
to set up a my sequel server with node
and plug those together and got those to
talking to each other and that was like
another aha moment and over time I just
kind of continue to add more and more
complexity and I even sure to add an
additional page the front-end so that
required me to learn how to use a router
and how to navigate between those two
pages and so that was kind of like the
full stack process for how I got this
goes back application running and then I
also learned a little bit of basic
testing after that
because I've heard the testing is good
and I really wanted to get in the habit
of doing TDD II so I learned about
testing and added tests and then finally
got this application running locally the
overall key was just to get a basic web
application running to keep it
manageable right it took me about a week
to get the initial MVP of the front when
I'm working and another week to get the
backend working because as Melanie I did
have to get working but I had to learn
all this stuff on my own and then the
last step was to actually learn how to
deploy this so that I can share with my
friends or my sister or whatnot and so
what I was like doing was I was doing
much like googling to understand how to
like deploy a web application and I read
a bunch of tutorials on go to Roku and
digitalocean and I want to be super
fancy I want to be legit so I think I'm
going to deploy with you they do
digitalocean
and frankly it was a little bit too
complicated for me at that stage I
couldn't really understand everything
that was going on in some residual
digitalocean documentation and
everything I was still just like putting
things together it was a little bit hazy
so I was like you know what I'm just
going to scratch this and I'm going to
use Heroku which was like you know it
took me like half an hour to deploy in
Heroku it was like simple and then you
know later on as I got better I was back
and I learned how to use digital ocean
and much more complicated deployment
processes but I want the lesson I
learned there was like when you're
beginning you kind of get all like shiny
object syndrome and you want to use all
these sophisticated tools that you hear
about and and stuff but I would just say
start with the basics get things working
and so the simpler the better and really
the goal is always just to finish and
not make it too complex where you get
like soap rushes and just like never
finish and give up so yeah I remember
when I deployed it my like eyes lit up
and I was like it was the best feeling
ever I was putting the link to all my
friends and my boyfriend my sister and
everything and it really gave me the
motivation to keep going
whereas if I had started with this big
ambitious project
I honestly probably would not have ever
finished and I was just given up 1/3 of
the way through or something but with
the accomplishment of getting through
each layer each step along the way I
just
motivated enough to kind of finish
another thing that I do when that when I
was in that stage of like okay I know a
lot of things but I don't know what to
do next is I would learn from other
people by meeting other people's code so
whether that's open source repos or
examples that you find online like I
know the react and redux repos for
example have a lot of examples of sample
applications I would kind of read
through those and really try to
understand how people think through
putting different parts of the
application together and honestly I
would copy a lot of the parts of the
code that I thought was useful or that I
liked or like their programming style
and honestly it's totally okay to copy
when you're learning this is how a lot
of us learn even some of the best
programmers that I know today that are
like kernel developers at Google they
started off by copying other people's
code and just like playing around with
it and like changing some parts and
learning how that works and so forth so
it's okay to learn from other people's
code and copy it as a beginner and then
over time as you get better it's hard to
write just as good code if you practice
more and more and another recommendation
that says don't get stuck forever if you
are if you ever get stuck as you're
trying to build your first second or
third or whenever web application then
make sure you have like a process for
how you go about debugging this stuff
right
first like look at the problem that
you're running into and really think
about it what what could be causing it
like lighted down maybe and like think
about all the possible ideas you have
for what could be causing this this
really forces you to think about the
problem and next time you run into this
you'll know like oh hi remember this
because I wrote it down and I I remember
thinking through how to solve this
problem and it'll be much easier to
solve the next time and then other
things are like learn to use the chrome
debugger in the web app like I mean
that's a huge lifesaver a no-brainer and
learn to use the Internet I often find
so many beginners who just like get
stuck and really just don't use the
internet enough and I'm honestly there's
so many answers online just learn from
other people there's people have run
into you there's 99 likely to my name is
percent likely chances someone has
wanted to use the problem you're running
into especially if you're a beginner and
building
pretty simple and basic to leverage them
leverage the internet and if you really
can't come to any answers asking opens
open those communities or freeze in the
free code camp communities ask on Stack
Overflow ask someone else try try to
find someone that you can ask
so in conclusion there's really no
simple answer to ok what do I do next
how do I get to the next step how do I
become a better developer I learned all
the basics
instead depending on your skills and
depending on how much you're willing to
learn and what your initial goals for
learning to program was just pick a
project and build something and start
small I'm slowly slowly layer up and I
would say if you've kind of done this
process and you made it through building
your first application you want to go
even deeper one thing that I did was I
would do I try to I started researching
like JavaScript books good books that
explain like basic computer science
concepts or design patterns and really
read through those and then try to be
building your applications once you've
kind of learned some of these new
concepts because it used to see how how
much better you're getting day-by-day
and week-by-week by the week as you
learn your things and look your you know
as you're kind of going through this
classes which is one of the hardest
parts of going from like a beginner to
like an advanced beginner kind of stage
you'll hit a lot of oh my god this sucks
so much I want to give up moments but
you'll also have those moments who are
like you're like oh wow this is so
amazing I don't want to put this down
and so every time you have that shitty
moment where you're like oh I don't want
to do this this is really frustrating
and getting stuck I feel dumb think
about all those awesome moments you're
going to have and really let those
motivate you because honestly
programming is really about this couple
of amazing moments you have that are
just like you don't want to give those
up for the for for the world but you
have to put up with a lot a lot of
shitty stuff along the way to get those
but it's totally worth it because the
feeling of like building something it is
unbelievable and I'm addicted to it now
and I hope that
by building your first or second or
third web application you will get
addicted to that feeling - I think
that's it for this one and I hope you
enjoyed it